so for a while now I've been saying that
fitness trackers don't tap into their
full potential a lot of them amount to
basically fancy pedometers that count
your calories and as I've talked about
in the past that's not even that
accurate I'm not saying that they're not
useful I'm just saying that I mean they
haven't really changed have they since
they first came along what can I do that
they didn't used to be able to do heart
rate monitoring great that's it
what I really like about the arrow ring
and why I think it's the perfect device
for a biohacker
is that it gives you a lot more granular
detail and some different type of detail
and this is really useful not just for
improving your fitness but actually for
improving your health your well-being
your focus your energy levels this is
something that I think it's been
possible for a long time but these are
the first guys that I think are really
doing it they're creating a health
tracker that can make you feel better
and perform better and I think that's
awesome
so the first arrow ring was launched
with a crowdfunding campaign and it was
really popular and it was very
successful
the ear ring too is an iterative update
which is nicer to look at much more
spelt and as it's just kind of catching
on getting momentum for many this will
be your first exposure to the device as
you can see is a ring very similar to
the Emotiv ring which I also reviewed at
an authority and thought was okay but
actually this is a nicer design and a
more impressive device being a ring of
course means that it's very low key you
don't notice it when you're wearing it
you forget all about it especially if
you're normally wearing it's not that
much heavy or that much different from
my wedding band at the same time it
means that you can still wear a watch
you can still wear another fitness
tracker on your wrist and it has
advantages because being on your finger
means that it can actually get a better
read of your heart rate as well as
picking up your body temperature and
that's one of the first things I'll
mention that the earring two measures
they're not many other health trackers
actually do in terms of battery life you
can go six days without charging it has
a memory built-in so you can go a long
time without needing to charge it you
won't lose your data it comes with a
very nice little charging stand that
makes it very quick and easy to top it
up the box is also really nice the
attention to detail is great for a small
startup it's waterproof so that's great
you can wear it in the shower etc and
generally it
really well-designed lots of
quality-of-life features attention to
detail and it makes it great to use the
downside normally of any ring shaped
fitness tracker is that it'll scratch
when you're exercising on your weights
etc that was a big problem with the
Emotiv ring that I reviewed however for
the earlier ring it's significantly less
of a problem it looks really nice and
it's only picked up really tiny Dinks
nothing too different from my actual
ring so there's no reason you can't keep
on whilst you're training of course
being worn on your hand doesn't mean
it's a bit harder for it to pick up
certain movements but I'll talk about
that a little bit more in a moment as
for what the earlier ring does its main
focus is on sleep and recovery so it's a
sleep tracker that you can wear during
the night and when you wake up in the
morning and check the app works for both
Android and iOS you'll be able to see a
breakdown of all your different sleep
stages how long it took me to get off to
sleep all the stuff that you'd normally
get on a Fitbit but with a lot more
extra detail as well that extra detail
includes things like your resting heart
rate but you don't just see the number
for your resting heart rate you also get
to see how quickly your heart rate drops
which tells you something about how
rested you are and whether you've been
too active just before you went to sleep
you can see things like your body
temperature as I mentioned which is
really interesting and that can
sometimes help to predict whether you
might be getting ill or something you'll
want to wear the ear ring to for a
little while because that will establish
a baseline for things like your body
temperature and then when you look at it
later on you can see when you've strayed
from that baseline too much and when
that might indicate that you're a little
bit unwell also if you work up during
the night how long it took me to get to
sleep and it'll show you your heart rate
variability and that's something that's
really interesting and it also track
this during the day
heart rate variability I've talked a
little bit about on this channel before
but I intend to talk about it more
basically your heart rate isn't a steady
boom-boom-boom
it varies slightly all the time and this
is due to whether you're breathing in or
breathing out that's good you want your
heart rate to vary when you breathe in
and breathe out it basically makes you
slightly more parasympathetic and
slightly more sympathetic however if
you're very stressed your heart rate
stays elevated and doesn't reduce when
you breathe out and therefore your high
rate variability goes down and this is
an indicator that you might be
stressed either mentally or physically
and that means that you might want to
take it easy the next day at the gym
actually I did get really ill just
recently I mean really ill I had like
multiple infections and my mouth filled
with ulcers and I had terrible
indigestion and I had to wear a mask
around Emmy so yeah pretty bad but is a
great opportunity to test that oh a ring
always look on the bright side and what
was really impressive was that the
earring noticed the elevated temperature
it noticed that my heart rate was like
90 BPM during the night that was my
resting heart rate and so it obviously
recognized that something was wrong
and told me to take it easy and that
might sound like something obvious that
any health tracker should be able to do
but most fitness trackers would just be
like you had an elevated heart rate
that's great you must have been getting
loads of activity you're not gonna out
of the park and then it would have been
like stop sitting around get up and
exercise so yeah I mean that's the great
thing about it it can recognize what's
actually going on in your body and
advise you on that basis up in the
morning you take a look at all this data
there's just much more to dive into in
the earlier app then there would be with
a Fitbit it's very accurate and it's
really interesting and if you are
passionate about this sort of stuff then
you'll love having that much data
presented and the fact that you can get
all this from a ring is really cool
what's more so that it then cholesterin
firm ation as well as information picked
up during the day to give you a
readiness score and this is basically
telling you whether you should take it
easy or whether you can go hard when you
are working out the next day when you're
focusing on work basically if your heart
rate is good your resting heart rate is
good if you had a good night's sleep if
you're not too stressed all these things
that will give you a better readiness
score and I'll say go for it hit it hard
at the gym but if your heart rate
variability is low if your heart rate is
high when it's resting if you work up a
lot during the night then it might say
to take it easy the next day something
else that arrow does though that's
different from other fitness trackers
and I think it's really cool is that it
doesn't just base this advice on what
happened the day before like so many
devices do instead it a look at your
week your month as a whole and look at
your baselines and hyper form and it'll
tell you them how serious that one night
of bad sleep is if it's one bad night
and you've had a great week then it'll
say you know carry on
you didn't have a great night's sleep
but you're gonna be alright however if
you've had 20 bad nights of sleep then
it's gonna tell you that you should
really take it easy and focus on your
recovery and this is really useful one
more thing I just want to show you here
that's really cool is that you can also
view your stats in the or a cloud here
and you can actually get a little bit
more data and you can display it in some
different ways and what I really like
here there's the ability to create a
chart where you look at two different
values overlaid on top of each other so
here's my deep sleep time and my
temperature deviation so we can see if
there's any relationship between my
temperature my body temperature and how
much deep sleep I'm getting it looks
like there is some correlation here
although it's definitely not one-to-one
here my body temperature goes all the
way up and my deep sleep goes all the
way down and that was obviously because
that's when I was ill you can put
anything here such as your respiration
your activity your spirit or e-rate your
activity your resting heart rate and
likewise you can put anything on this
end and see how they line up so you can
see if any changes you're making are
actually having an impact again you just
don't get this sort of data this sort of
flexibility with many other trackers I
missed the Microsoft band actually that
was a really good tracker I had a really
good website - the amount of data here
is massive and the app can be a little
bit tricky to fiddle through sometimes
but it's being constantly updated and it
does give a lot of information pretty
much anything you see you can tap and
it'll give you further explanation and
often this leads to a link over at the
or a blog where it'll talk about what
things mean how you can improve them etc
so it is very detailed but it is also
accessible for those that prefer you
know simple advice obviously many of you
know that I'm recently a new parent I've
got a new beautiful little daughter
called Amelia a virgin it's key and
wonderful there she is she does prevent
me from sleeping quite as I'd like to in
fact on average at the moment I'm
getting four hours
if I'm lucky sometimes three sometimes
five we're both exhausted and fitting
work and things around that it's a
challenge anyone's a parent will know
this also means however this is a
fantastic time to be testing a device
like this I've really put it through its
paces and I can say it's super accurate
so if I wake up just to change a nappy
for five minutes that all will be
reflected in the app however there were
a couple of shortcomings that I also
noticed one is that it won't pick up a
daytime nap I guess it assumes you're
not gonna sleep during the day and
that's a bit of a shame or didn't when I
did it anyways that's a bit of a shame
because that is a great coping strategy
and a great life hack and it's something
I'd like them to consider implementing
in the future it also didn't notice one
night when I completely didn't sleep
when we were actually giving birth well
Hannah was giving birth and I was in the
delivery room with her I didn't sleep
for a whole night and I was hoping that
the app would say you know serious
serious need for recovery do something
about it however it didn't say that it
kind of assumed I wasn't wearing the
ring it acted as though I just hadn't
recorded my sleep that night and that's
a shame obviously considering that it
knew I was wearing it because you know
it was attached and it's picking up my
heart rate and things for that whole
time so that's something else that they
could maybe look at but these are
extreme and unusual circumstances on the
whole the sleep tracking is incredibly
accurate and I will say that it's the
best sleep tracking experience that I've
ever used so that's pretty high praise
during the day the aura ring too will
continue to track things like your steps
your calories burn your activity levels
and all this is also used in that
readiness score that you get however
here it doesn't perform quite as well it
can detect some activities automatically
such as runs and that's really
impressive considering it's just a ring
and that must be quite tricky obviously
the kind of exercises I do things like
bench presses pull-ups often won't get
recorded I'll have to add them in
manually that's a shame but it's
completely understandable and attempts
to try and auto detect exercises such as
from companies like Garmin have been
more of a hindrance than a help to be
honest it is a shame however that if you
miss a routine if you forget to add that
you did a workout on one day you can't
go back to a previous day and add it in
retrospect and that is a bit of a shame
I spoke to some people are about this
and they said it's because the algorithm
is so complicated
drastically changed your readiness score
and sure that would be annoying but at
least it would be slightly more accurate
still though barring a month at the
ready in a score is based on your you
know biological metrics it shouldn't
really matter too much your heart rate
is either strong or it's not it doesn't
really matter whether it's noticed it's
because you worked out or because you
didn't for those that like to have
perfectly accurate data though that's a
bit of a shame what's also a shame is
that on Android at the moment there's no
way of syncing this with other apps that
means no MyFitnessPal that means no
Google health it means you can't wear it
with another tracker with a Fitbit or a
Garmin and then have it have that add
the workouts for you you can do this on
Apple by syncing it with apple's
healthkit and i've been assured it is
coming to android very soon in 2019 so
whilst it's not ideal is something's
going to be fixed soon and until then
you can just add the activities yourself
just don't forget to do it the step
counting I also wasn't a huge fan of
because it seems to be way too high
compared to other devices again I spoke
to her about this and they told me it's
because they're not actually tracking
specific steps so much as the metabolic
equivalent so it's not that I took 2,000
steps it so that my movement was the
equivalent of 2,000 steps in terms of
the calories I've burned and in some
ways that's useful but it's a bit
confusing because in the app it actually
calls them steps it doesn't say this and
at the same time it'd be nice to have a
pedometer in there as well
especially seeing as it went to sync up
with another device you can use that way
so again it's not a huge issue you can
just count steps another way with a
wrist one device and like I said
counting steps is a bit pointless in my
opinion anyways however it is something
I hope that they'll add soon and it
could be a bit clearer in the app in
short I'd say it's not the best fitness
tracker then it's not going to replace a
running watch it's not going to tell you
things like your bo2 max or your stride
or cadence you can't use it to track
your GPS route or likewise you're not
gonna want to use it to log all of your
workouts and things it's something
different it's a health tracker more
than a fitness tracker and I think
that's great because fitness trackers
like I say they've become boring we need
something like this and it's just a
great example of how else we can use
this technology to learn more about
ourselves to get more data to perform
better and I think that's awesome and if
you're a biohacker you're bound to
really enjoy that for everyone else I
still had
recommended purchase I think it's really
cool it's really small so great way to
get a better insight into your health
it's a little bit costly considering
some of the downsides so for Android
users I would say maybe just wait until
they bring that ability to synchronize
with Google health but if you're into
this sort of thing go for it I think
it's a really great device and something
really different I hope they continue
down the track and I can't wait to see
what they continue to add own support
for the app has been really good I've
seen lots of updates already onboarding
they've added just got a firmware update
so who knows what else is coming I'm
gonna keep adding more content on this
topic over at the blog probably
occasional videos I want to talk about
my experiences as a new parent and using
this to track sleep so stay tuned if you
want to hear more about the ear ring -
and I'd love to know in the comments
down below what you think about this and
of me doing reviews like this on the
channel in general so I hope you found
this video useful interesting guys if
you did then please leave a like please
share it around and comment down below
all those things massively help me out
and I'll see you next time bye for now
and I just wanted to quickly apologize
for the lack of content recently between
having a baby and Christmas and then
getting really ill I've not been quite
as productive as usual but I'm back full
time now and a lot of the stuff that
I've been promising is on the way
I'm really close to doing the ninja
training video that also took a bit
longer because that to do so much
research I've been really working on a
good script plus I want to edit it
really well so hopefully it's worth the
wait that should be the next video after
this one so stay tuned if that sounds
good and I'll see you next time bye for
now
you